alors que défilent jubilaire reste
introuvable depuis le 16 décembre 2020
les révélations les indices autour de la
sphère se multiplient un an de mystère
et un nouveau rebondissement coup de
théâtre énième rebondissement il faut
dire c'est une affaire incroyable si
c'est du jubilaire son mari reste depuis
le début de l' enquête le principal
suspect il aurait pu bénéficier de
l'aide de complices notamment sa femme
actuelle séverine a placé en garde à vue
le 15 décembre dernier pour suspicion de
recel de cadavres les enquêteurs peuvent
la suspectaient de savoir où se trouve
le corps d delphine jubile armée est un
autre élément qui vient relancer les
soupçons autour de ces deux villes a
notamment des échanges qu'il aurait eu
avec son codétenu marco à la prison de
toulouse s'est saoulé retenue il va lui
dire qu'il a enterré sa femme n'est pas
suffisamment profond des confidences
plus précisément qu'il aurait fait
avouant clairement le crime de sa femme
et les raisons du drame il aurait
d'abord vu un message de l'amant de sa
femme avec el texto tél il a pris son
téléphone des mains et a vu les messages
c'est ça qui l'a février qui aurait même
confié à son codétenu des courriers
destinés à sa femme séverine avec
certains messages codés je pense qu'il
avait peur que le camp réapparaissent
voudrait donner des instructions à sa
compagne qui sait où se trouve le corps
alors les aveux de ces deux jubilaires à
ses codétenus pour est il vraiment tout
faire basculer
je pense merci à sébastien devaux qui
discutera avec beauchemin kastanidis
verront chez l'opticien
merci d'être là shell dollars aux
nouveaux détectives merci est vraiment
la sphère jubila ça passionne les
français c'est la une du parisien encore
aujourd'hui et c'est vrai que connaissez
tout ça par coeur qu'a dit le fameux
codétenus marco aux enquêteurs dont ce
fameux marco en fait qui s'appelle marc
aurèle c'est son vrai prénom comme comme
le philosophe c'est un homme de 36 ans
qui va débarquer à la prison de seysses
où est détenu cédric jubile arts au mois
d'août il faut préciser contexte à
savoir qu'on est dans un contexte où
c'est vrai que je suis là et donc à l'
isolement 22h à peu près
par jour
il ya énormément de pressions s'exercent
sur lui puisque les codétenus lui dise
pour schématiser dit nous et delphine
d'innover delphine et le premier kill à
prendre la défense parce qu'il en fait
ce qui se passe c'est qu'il est il est
un petit peu attaquées par les autres
côté exactement et marco prend sa
défense danser le pommier vraiment
apprendre sa nourrice instaure un climat
de confiance absolue dans exactement en
fait ils sont dans dans deux cellules
qui sont mitoyennes et ça ils vont
commencer à discuter et il se passe
aussi par le phénomène du yo-yo avec un
yoyo et qu'est ce qu'on appelle le yoyo
il se passe des choses cannabis annabi
qui canalise disons le et ce qui est
très important pour cédric puisqu'on
sait que c'est un consommateur en gros
consommateurs de produits studio alors
donc il va raconter à marco apparemment
que il aurait donc assassiner des fines
il a carrément lui raconter la scène des
faits va lui rapporter toute l'histoire
il lui dit dont potentiel c'est un soir
il était je crois où
il n'était pas loin elle est en bas en
train de regarder la télé je compte des
arguments et il explique à ce que
détenir ce sont les paroles du co
détenus savent assurer à votre arrivée
il a expliqué qu' abandonner il a besoin
de son chargeur il va descendre
exactement il va trouver belle chine en
train de texter son amant l'enam aux
amants de montauban savall énervé il va
regarder il à prendre le téléphone et
voilà il va finir par la poignarder et
il dira même au codétenu qui rapporte
ses propos ces imbéciles les enquêteurs
n'ont même pas trouvé le couteau ce qui
est sérieux ça choquant alors la
nouvelle compagne de cédric est au coeur
de ces révélations pourquoi parce qu'en
fait non seulement il a révélé le crime
mais il va révéler aussi à ce qu détenus
où se trouverait le cadavre de delphine
à savoir dans une petite ferme a à peu
près à vue de nez de kilomètres de là
dans une ferme abandonnée qui a été
incendiée au mois d'avril dernier est en
fait il a missionné en quelque sorte ce
co détenu de rentrer en contact avec
sedrine qui connaîtrait en fait elle
aussi le lieu où le corps aurait été
enterré et voilà d'elle ce pardon pas
delsinne séverine
elle doit conduire si vous voulez ce co
détenu pour qu'il déplace le cadavre et
c'est la raison pour laquelle elle a été
entendue le placer en garde à vue pour
recel de cadavres d'accord i alors il ya
eu un autre dossier aussi une histoire
de la couette sinon ya eu c'est tristan
david mais qu'il avait lavé la couette à
4 heures du matin et en fait avant que
les policiers aillent met pas du tout en
fait quand les policiers sont venus chez
lui la quoi tu étais là c'est ça alors
quand les policiers arrivent s'agit de
trois policières on va rappeler
l'histoire la cua puisqu'il avait dit
c'est david enfin le frère de la
république avait dit que la couette
arrêter la vague 4 heures du matin
exactement oui c'est pas tout à fait
exact ce qui s'est passé c'est que
lorsque les trois femmes gendarmes sont
intervenus à la suite de l'appel d'éric
chevillard pour la disparition de sa
femme étant effectivement constaté
qu'une machine a été lancé une machine
avec notamment des paires de chaussettes
dépareillées mais absolument pas la
couette la couette elle l a été lavé à
peu près 35 heures après d'accord il
n'ya pas la couette dans laquelle
delphine a été enfin dans laquelle elle
dormait il n'y a pas la couette dans le
lave linge au moment où les gendarmes
rentrer dans la maison d'accord alors
aujourd'hui est ce que les enquêteurs
sont persuadés que cédric et comme ils
le sont ouais c'est sûr il le sent
toujours parce que il y a toujours
malgré tout un faisceau d'indicés graves
et concordants c'est la définition de la
mise en examen qui laisse à penser que
cédric est toujours potentiellement
l'auteur du crime alors ils envoyaient
des lettres à sa veillée compagne avec
des codes c'est sa part exactement des
codes donc où il disait un moment il a
dit à deux mots qui sont qui sont qui
sont qui sont us est d'abord il lui dit
qu'il a envie qu'elle lui manque c'est
ça il a en fait il explique son mal être
il lui demande aussi de ramener quelques
cd de system of a down qui est son
lorimer des chiffres mais on décide à
les décoder ces deux suites de chiffres
correspondent à des lettres en fait
l'écho les enquêteurs ont réussi à
décoder un qu'il gardait c'est quoi les
deux mots absolument alors les deux mots
c'est j'ai envie de toi avec des doubles
de chiffres qui donnent des lettres
c'est comme quand on décode avec un
travail d'expert mais le code était
assez facile à déchiffrer il y avait un
autre code aussi où il se fout de la
gueule de suri arrivons à des
positionnements d'où la quasi certitude
des enquêteurs qu'en fait ces codes sont
là pour se moquer d'eux voilà c'est tout
kim provoqué visiblement il ya ceux qui
regardent
bonne lecture les [ __ ] si vous trouvez
le code par exactement la sr de toulouse
appréciera le temps et c'est là où vous
allez apparaître alors c'est là où je
vais paraître parce que c'est vrai que
j'apparais dans un décor dresser sa
giberne absolument en fait c'est bien
pour être crédible marco il dit aux
enquêteurs moi j'ai des éléments et ces
éléments ce sont des lettres que cédric
lui aurait confié parce que cédric
savait que marco allaient être libérés
donc il a écrit les lettres pour
séverine mater dans cette lettre les
enquêteurs à leur grande stupéfaction
voix demande à cyril hanouna de nous
aider les enquêteurs ne comprennent pas
exactement pourquoi est-ce que cédric a
écrit ça c'est une manière de dire à
séverine tu peux lui faire confiance
parce que cyril hanouna et le surnom de
marco dans la présente et ça c'est voilà
c'est un corse de trente six ans qui
porte beau qui a de la gouaille que l'on
surnomme si les trois marques au sol
humains et donc il dit il dit grâce à ça
tu peux lui faire confiance vas-y mais
c'est ça en fait c'est le note c'est le
nom de code de marque peu et ça s'est
passé correctement ccc et du cou
séverine va lui faire confiance fort de
sa est ce que tu penses que si marcos
son surnom ça avait été un nikos lui
n'aura pas fait
quand même sincèrement est alors encore
moins bien
donc la sphère est en train de rebondir
'le là on arrive il ya là on arrive
presque voilà au dénouement oui il faut
vous pensez pas parce qu'avec les aveux
de marc ou avec la témoigne le
témoignage de marcoux donc c'est sûr il
ya il ya des éléments à charge dans ce
dossier mais on voit très bien que les
avocats de la défense n'ont pas dit leur
dernier mot d'un savoir que
régulièrement il formula il m'en faudra
donner aujourd'hui nous demandent la
libération de leur cause de la couette
justement parce que la couette avaient
été versés au dossier d'entreprise fait
ok avec d'erreurs au début le podomètre
aussi aliments le podomètre en fait ce
qui est indiqué qu'il avait fait
simplement 40 pas et en fait c'était une
erreur il avait fait 200 m de recherche
incroyable voilà il ya eu des erreurs
dans le témoignage de marco peut être
sujet à caution parce qu'il faut savoir
par exemple il a déjà été condamné
notamment pour subornation de témoins
faux témoins qui est aussi un
manipulateur éventuelles là il ya une
demande en ligne est beaucoup de détails
marque il donne beaucoup de détails et
donne énormément de marcos cyril
je te le dis donc sacré donne sa
crédibilité ne peut absolument pas être
remise merci l'air est doux et donc du
coup la demande de mise en liberté sur
un statut et vendredi mais saura
vendredi si cédric jubila reste en
prison ou pas va il va être va rester ou
pas comment on sait qu'il va rester en
prison il ya quinze jours je veux pas me
substituer au juge mais mon avis
personnel je pense qu'effectivement ils
resteront ils restent en détention
détention